foreign
empiricism and rationalism
[Music]
on many occasions you have criticized
philosophic and scientific empiricism
can you state your objections more
precisely
in a sense empiricism has developed a
kind of mind-body dualism
of a quite unacceptable type
just at the time when from another point
of view it rejected such dualism
within an empiricist framework one
approaches the study of the body as a
topic in the Natural Sciences concluding
that the body is constructed of varied
and specialized organs which are
extremely complex and genetically
determined in their basic character
and that these organs interact in a
manner which is also determined by human
biology
on the other hand empiricism insists
that the brain is a tabula rasa empty
unstructured uniform at least as far as
a cognitive structure is concerned
I don't see any reason to believe that I
don't see any reason to believe that the
little finger is a more complex organ
than those parts of the human brain
involved in the higher mental faculties
on the contrary it is not unlikely that
these are among the most complex
structures in the universe there is no
reason to believe that the higher mental
faculties are in some manner dissociated
from this complexity of organization
one can say that the dualism introduced
by empiricist Dogma is methodological
rather than substantive
that is to say it is taken for granted
that the body must be studied by the
ordinary methods of science
but in the case of the Mind certain
preconceptions have been imposed which
have virtually removed this study from
the domain of scientific inquiry in fact
this dogmatism seems to be even more
striking in the most recent period
Hume for example really did his best to
show that his Elementary principles
concerning the acquisition of human
knowledge were sufficient to cover an
interesting class of cases
and challenged his opponents to produce
a legitimate idea that could not be
derived from sense impression by his
principles
there is a certain kind of ambiguity in
his procedure here since in part he
seems to be engaged in a kind of
scientific inquiry trying to show that
certain principles he proposed were in
fact adequate to cover the crucial cases
while at other times he relies on these
principles to demonstrate that some
notion is illegitimate since it cannot
be derived by them
an argument that rests on our accepting
his not very plausible principles
concerning the nature of the Mind
Hume regarded the principle of inductive
reasoning as a kind of animal instinct
which would appear to be an empirical
assumption in modern versions his
assumptions have often been converted
into Dogma presupposed without serious
effort to show them to be valid or to
reply to classical criticisms that were
raised against these principles
there is no reason to believe today that
hume's principles are anything
resembling them are adequate to account
for our ideas or our knowledge and
beliefs
nor to think that they have any
particular significance
there is no place for any a priori
Doctrine concerning the complexity of
the brain or its uniformity as far as
the higher mental functions are
concerned
we must proceed to the investigation of
the diverse cognitive structures
developed normally by human beings in
the course of their maturation and their
relation to the physical and social
environment seeking to determine as best
we can the principles which govern these
cognitive structures
once a certain understanding of the
nature of these systems has been
obtained
then we can reasonably study the basis
on which they are acquired
in my opinion the little that we know
about these questions suggest that the
mind like the body is in effect the
system of organs
we could call them mental organs by
analogy that is to say highly specific
systems organized according to a genetic
program that determines their function
their structure the process of their
development in quite a detailed manner
the particular realization of these
fundamental principles naturally depends
on their interaction with the
environment
as in the case of the visual system
which we mentioned previously
if that is correct the mind is a complex
system of interacting faculties which do
not develop by means of uniform
principles of general intelligence
it is constituted of mental organs just
a specialized and differentiated as
those of the body
it is for that reason doubtless that you
insist on the autonomy of grammar on the
fact that grammatical structures do not
depend on other cognitive systems
does it seem impossible to you to think
of language and the structure of
knowledge in terms of the same model
I have nothing against comparisons but I
wonder whether we are likely to learn
very much by proceeding in this
direction
note that one never tends toward that
kind of proposal in physiology
no one suggests that we should study the
structure of the eye and the heart and
then search for analogies between them
one does not expect to find meaningful
analogies if the Mind consists of a
system of mental organs and interaction
certainly but fundamentally different in
their structure
we need not expect to find fruitful
analogies among them
to make myself clear
I am not about to propose all this as a
new Dogma to replace empiricist Doctrine
on the contrary just as in studying the
body you must simply retain an open mind
on this subject
we know a little about a number of
cognitive systems language being the
most interesting case at the moment
that small degree of insight seems to me
to suggest the preceding conclusions
the important thing of course is to
determine the deeper principles and the
detailed structure of various cognitive
systems their modes of interaction and
the general conditions which each system
satisfies
if one finds that these systems are
acquired in a uniform manner with very
little specific structure very well
but for the present at least it seems to
me that quite different conclusions are
indicated
that is what I mean when I say that one
need not expect to find analogies
nor phenomena of interdependence
however certain psychologists assert
that perception exerts an influence on
the potential structure of sentences
an essential aspect of your critique of
empiricism is the rationalist hypothesis
the structure of the brain is determined
apriori by the genetic code the brain is
programmed to analyze experience and to
construct knowledge out of that
experience that may seem shocking
I don't see anything shocking in that
proposition
in physiology no one has ever accepted
anything analogous to empiricist Dogma
with regard to the mind
no one finds it outlandish to ask the
question what genetic information
accounts for the growth of arms instead
of wings
why should it be shocking to raise
similar questions with regard to the
brain and mental faculties
we are back to the methodological
dualism of the empiricists
that position does not suit contemporary
human Sciences
especially not behaviorist psychology or
perhaps even Piaget
though his position seems to be obscure
in crucial respects
Piaget considers himself to be an
anti-impericist but some of his writings
suggest to me that he is mistaken in
this conclusion
Piaget develops a certain constructive
interactionism
new knowledge is constructed through
interaction with the environment
but the fundamental question is evaded
how is this knowledge constructed
and why just this kind of knowledge and
not some other
Piaget does not give any intelligible
answer as far as I can make out
the only answer that I can imagine is to
suppose an innate genetic structure
which determines the process of
maturation
insofar as he considers it wrong to give
such an answer he falls back into
something like the empiricism that he
wants to reject
what he postulates is nowhere near
sufficient
it seems to me to account for the
specific course of cognitive development
that is not to deny the very great
importance of the research that has been
conducted by Piaget and his group at
Geneva
it has opened up entirely New
Perspectives in the study of human
knowledge
it is primarily the interpretation of
their results
which seems extremely doubtful to me in
particular their attitude to what Piaget
calls
in naism
which seems to me altogether wrong
in philosophy the same problems appear
in some of the work of Quine for example
at times he asserts the theories are
developed by induction which he
identifies with conditioning at other
times he says the opposite
theories are not determined solely by
conditioning or induction
but involve abstract hypotheses
ultimately originating from some innate
capacity
in recent years he has oscillated
between these two positions
functionalism
the tendency of thought which has fought
hardest against the independence of
grammar as a mental organ is without
doubt functionalism
it tends to explain the form of language
by attributing a determining role to its
function
this function is presumed to be
communication
everything in language must contribute
to communication to a better
communication
and inversely
nothing is linguistic which does not
contribute to communication
isn't that a fairly accurate portrait
functionalism holds that the use of
language influences its form
this might be understood as a variant of
empiricist Doctrine about language
learning one that makes very little
sense
as far as I can see
but we might understand the fundamental
ideas quite differently
for example George Miller and I
suggested about 15 years ago that there
may be a functional explanation for the
organization of language with
grammatical transformations
which would be a well-designed system
corresponding to a certain organization
of short and long-term memory for
example
if one could demonstrate that it would
be interesting but what does that mean
basically what would the analogous
observation mean for some physical organ
say the heart to be sure the heart has a
function to pump blood one may sensibly
say that the structure of the heart is
determined by that function
but suppose we ask the ontogenic
question
how does our heart become what it is
how does it grow in the individual from
the embryo to its final form in the
mature organism
the answer is not functional the heart
does not develop in the individual
because it would be useful to carry out
a certain function
but rather because the genetic program
determines that it will develop as it
does
every organ has certain functions
but these functions do not determine the
ontogenic development of the organism
nobody would suggest that a group of
cells decides that perhaps it would be a
good idea to become a heart because such
an organ is necessary to pump blood
if this group of cells becomes a heart
it is due to the information present in
the genetic code
which determines the structure of the
organism
there is a place for functional
explanation
but it is on the level of evolution
it is possible that a heart develops in
the course of evolution in order to
satisfy a certain function
of course I'm simplifying enormously but
this is a point that is useful to keep
in mind
functional explanation does not relate
to the way organs develop in the
individual
let's go back to linguistics here
comparable remarks can be made
to my knowledge no functional principle
with very great plausibility has yet
been proposed
but suppose that someone proposes a
principle which says
the form of language is such and such
because having that form permits a
function to be fulfilled
a proposal of this sort would be
appropriate at the level of evolution of
the species or of language
not at the level of acquisition of
language by an individual one would
suppose
as a consequence insofar as your
Linguistics is a theory of language and
of the acquisition of language by an
individual
functionalism cannot be retained as a
fundamental principle
inversely one might note that the
legitimacy of the dependency relation
between function and structure is not
even a problem for functionalist
linguists
because their aim is not to explain the
acquisition of language but to describe
a linguistic Corpus
I doubt that functionalist linguists
would accept that characterization
if they mean that antigenic development
is directed by functional considerations
that seems just as plausible to me as
suggesting that the development of the
heart in the individual is Guided by the
utility of having an organ that pumps
blood
and about as well supported by the
factual evidence
or they might say that questions
touching on the basis of language
acquisition do not concern them
The crucial point however
seems to me that there is no real debate
about the validity of functionalism at
the generally vague level on which we
discuss the hypothetical evolution of
the species or in the study of language
change
and there is no sensible way to invoke
functional Notions as explanatory
Concepts at the synchronic or ontogenic
level
so far as I can see
it also seems to me important to avoid
certain vulgarization with respect to
the use of language
there is no reason to believe to repeat
myself once again that language
essentially serves instrumental ends or
that the essential purpose of language
is communication as is often said
at least if we mean by communication
something like transmitting information
or inducing belief
someone who claims that this is the
essential purpose of language must
explain just what he means by it and why
he believes this function and no other
to be so uniquely significant
language is used in many different ways
language can be used to transmit
information but it also serves many
other purposes to establish relations
among people to express or clarify
thought
for play for Creative mental activity to
gain understanding and so on in my
opinion there is no reason to Accord
privilege status to one or the other of
these modes
forced to choose I would have to say
something quite classical and rather
empty
language serves essentially for the
expression of thought
I know of no reason to suppose that
instrumental ends or transmission of
information about one's beliefs or other
actions that might reasonably be called
communication unless of course the term
is used quite evacuously
have some unique significance compared
with other characteristic uses of
language
in fact what is meant by the assertion
that such and such is the goal of
language
or its essential purpose is far from
Clear
once again this plurality of modes is
characteristic of the most banal and
normal use of language
it is hard to know just what people mean
when they say that language is
essentially an instrument of
communication
if you press them a bit and ask them to
be more precise you will often find for
example that under communication they
include communication with oneself
once you admit that the notion of
communication loses all content the
expression of thought becomes a kind of
communication
these proposals seem to be either false
or quite empty depending on the
interpretation that is given even with
the best of will
it is also vague that discussion remains
mystifying I have no idea why such
proposals are so often made frequently
with such fervor or what on Earth
they're supposed to signify
the real question is how does this
organism function and what is its mental
and physical structure
empiricism and in particular
functionalism has enjoyed an enormous
success in spite of all the
demonstrations that have been made of
its errors today it Still Remains a
dominant philosophy
to what do you attribute that success
that power to survive to a conjunction
of ideology and politics
on that point we must be careful because
here we enter into speculation when
certain ideas are dominant it is very
reasonable to ask why
the reason could be that they are
plausibly regarded as true they have
been verified Etc
but in the case where they are without
empirical foundations and have little
initial plausibility
the question arises more sharply
the answer may actually lie in the
domain of ideology
of course the argument here must be
indirect
because we don't have any direct means
of determining the ideological basis for
the acceptance gained by a certain
Doctrine
perhaps the instrumentalist conception
of language is related to the general
belief that Human Action in its
Creations along with the intellectual
structure of human beings are designed
for the satisfaction of certain physical
needs
food well-being security
Etc
Why Try to reduce intellectual and
artistic achievement to Elementary needs
is the attraction of the several
variants of empiricist Doctrine based on
experimental verification
hardly there is no such verification
does it derive from their explanatory
power no because they can explain very
little
is it due to some analogy to other
systems about which we know more no
again the systems known to biology are
totally different
animal intelligence seems to be quite
different so too the physical structures
of the human organism the rational
hypotheses which we can produce to
explain the dominance of empiricist
doctrines do not apply
it should be noted that empiricist
Doctrine has not merely been accepted
for a long period it was hardly even
questioned but rather simply assumed
tacitly as the framework within which
thinking and research must proceed
perhaps then some sociological Factor
might explain in a natural way why this
point of view has been so widely adopted
we can ask ourselves who accepts and
disseminates these doctrines
essentially
the Intelligentsia including scientists
and non-scientists what is the social
role of the Intelligentsia as I have
said
it has been quite characteristically
manipulation and social control in all
its varied forms
for example in those systems called
socialist the technical intelligencia
belongs to the elite that designs and
propagates the ideological system and
organizes and controls the society
fact that has long been noted by the
non-bolshevik left
Walter Kendall for example has pointed
out that Lenin in such pamphlets as what
is to be done conceived of the
proletariat as a tabula rasa upon which
the radical Intelligentsia must imprint
a socialist consciousness
the metaphor is a good one for the
Bolsheviks the radical Intelligentsia
must bring a socialist Consciousness to
the masses from the outside
as party members the Intelligentsia must
organize and control Society in order to
bring socialist structures into
existence
this set of beliefs corresponds very
well to the demands of the technocratic
Intelligentsia it offers them a very
important social role
and in order to justify such practices
it is very useful to believe that human
beings are empty organisms malleable
controllable
easy to govern and so on with no
essential need to struggle to find their
own way and to determine their own fate
for that empiricism is quite suitable
so from this point of view
it is perhaps no surprise that denial of
any essential Human Nature has been so
prominent in much of the left-wing
Doctrine
analogously
the modern Intelligentsia and the
capitalist societies that of the United
States for example have a certain access
to prestige and Power by serving the
state
so much the same is true for the liberal
intelligencia in the west service to the
state includes social manipulation
preservation of capitalist ideology in
capitalist institutions within the
framework of State capitalism in this
case as well the concept of an empty
organism is useful
it is plausible that statist ideologues
and administrators are attracted by this
Doctrine because it is so convenient for
them in eliminating any moral barrier to
manipulation and control
these remarks apply only for the last
century more or less
before that the situation is rather
different
without doubt at an earlier period
empiricism was associated with
Progressive social Doctrine in
particular with classic liberalism
although as we were discussing that was
not always the case
one may recall the ideas of the young
Marx who was far from empiricist
Doctrine and spirit
why this link between Progressive social
thought and empiricist Doctrine
perhaps because empiricism seemed to
have and in a certain way did have
Progressive social implications in
contrast to reactionary and determinist
doctrines According to which the
existing social structures slavery
autocracy the feudal hierarchy the role
of women were founded on unchanging
Human Nature
against that Doctrine the idea that
human nature is a historical product had
a progressive content as it also did one
might argue throughout the early period
of capitalist industrialization
the determinist doctrines in question
maintain that certain people were born
to be Slaves by their very nature
or consider the oppression of woman
which was also founded on such Concepts
or wage labor willingness to rent
oneself through the market is considered
one of the fundamental and immutable
human properties in a version of the
human Essence characteristic of the era
of capitalism
in the face of such doctrines as these
it is natural for Advocates of social
change to adopt the extreme position
that human nature is a myth nothing but
a product of History
but that position is incorrect human
nature exists immutable except for
biological changes in the species
but that is not the same definition of
human nature it is no longer a matter of
defining a psychology of individual
character
certainly we can distinguish between
theories that assign a determinate
social status to particular individuals
or groups by virtue of their alleged
intrinsic nature for example some are
born to be slaves and theories that hold
that there are certain biological
constants characteristic of the species
which may of course assume very
different forms as the social and
material environment varies
there is much to be said about all of
these matters it seems to me that one
might suggest in a very speculative
manner that such factors is the ones I
have mentioned entered into the success
of empiricism among the Intelligentsia
I've discussed this question a bit in
Reflections on language stressing The
crucial and sometimes overlooked point
but speculation about these matters of
ideology is quite independent of the
validity of the specific doctrines in
question
it is when doctrines of little Merit
gain wide and unquestioned Credence that
such speculations as these become
particularly appropriate
in Reflections I also mentioned that
even at the earliest stages it is not so
obvious that empiricism was simply a
progressive Doctrine in terms of its
social impact as is very widely assumed
there has been some interesting work in
the past few years for example on the
philosophical origins of racism
particularly by Harry Brackett which
suggests a much more complex history
it seems that racist Doctrine developed
in part as a concomitant of the colonial
system
for Fairly obvious reasons
and it is a fact that some leading
empiricist philosophers lock for example
were connected to the Colonial system in
their professional lives and that racist
attitudes were commonly Advanced during
this period by Major philosophers among
others
it is perhaps not unreasonable to
speculate that the success of empiricist
beliefs in some circles at least might
be associated with the fact that they
offer a certain possibility for
formulating racist Doctrine in a way
that is difficult to reconcile with
traditional dualist Concepts concerning
the human essence
Bracken has suggested plausibly it seems
to me
that racist Doctrine raises conceptual
difficulties within the framework of
dualist beliefs
that is if they are taken seriously
Cartesian dualism raises what he is
called a modest conceptual barrier to
racist Doctrine
the reason for that is simple
Cartesian Doctrine characterizes humans
as thinking beings
they are metaphysically distinct from
non-humans possessing a thinking
substance
race coguitance
which is unitary and invariant
it does not have color for example there
are no black mines or white mines you're
either a machine or else you're a human
being
just like any other human being in
essential Constitution
the differences are superficial
insignificant
they have no effect on the invariant
human essence
I think it is not an exaggeration to see
in Cartesian Doctrine a conceptual
barrier
a modest one as Bracken carefully
explains Against Racism
on the other hand the empiricist
framework does not offer an analogous
characterization of the human essence
a person is a collection of accidental
properties and color is one of them
it is thus somewhat easier to formulate
racist beliefs in this framework
although it is not inevitable
I don't want to exaggerate the
importance of these speculations
but
it is worth investigating the question
whether Colonial ideology did in fact
exploit the possibilities made available
by empiricist Doctrine to formulate more
easily the kind of racist beliefs that
were employed to justify conquest and
oppression
it is unfortunate that the carefully
qualified speculations that have been
proposed for investigation have evoked a
rather hysterical response and some
outright falsification on the part of a
number of philosophers who are as
Bracken has observed quite willing to
consider and even Advance very explicit
proposals concerning a possible relation
between rationalism and various
oppressive doctrines racism among them
thus indicating that it is not the
nature of the inquiry but rather its
object that they consider intolerable
I must emphasize again that these
speculations or any others concerning
the ideological or social factors that
contribute to the success of any
Doctrine must be recognized for what
they are
speculations which are at best
suggestive
again questions of this kind arise
especially when a Doctrine enjoys a
great deal of Attraction and success
among the Intelligentsia in spite of
little factual support or explanatory
value
this is the case with empiricism in my
opinion
empiricism thus finds support from both
the right and the left that explains why
generative grammar is often attacked by
the progressive Intelligentsia precisely
because of your reference to the
hypothesis of innate ideas as it is
called that is the genetic limitations
imposed on language
this hypothesis is accused of idealism
that is true as you say but the
characterization is quite irrational
a consistent materialist would consider
it as self-evident that the mind has
very important innate structures
physically realized in some manner why
should it be otherwise
as I have already mentioned if we assume
that human beings belong to the
biological world
then we must expect them to resemble the
rest of the biological world
their physical Constitution their organs
and the principles of maturation are
genetically determined
there is no reason for supposing the
mental world to be an exception the
hypothesis which naturally comes to mind
is that these mental systems
unusual in the biological world because
of their extraordinary complexity
exhibit the general characteristics of
known biological systems
I would emphasize once again that even
qualitative considerations of the most
evident kind suggest this conclusion
it is difficult to see any other
explanation for the fact that extremely
complicated and intricate structures are
required in a like manner among all
individuals on the basis of very limited
and often imperfect data
certain psychologists are still trying
to make Apes talk as a result they deny
the qualitative difference between human
beings and animals a difference which
you have adopted from cartesianism and
restated in the light of Modern Biology
to those who are opposed to ineism take
the same position as these psychologists
I don't want to speak for others let's
consider this question of human
uniqueness
imagine a martian scientist who studies
human beings from the outside without
any prejudice suppose that he has a
great deal of time in his disposal say
thousands of years
he notices immediately that there exists
on earth a unique organism
whose conditions of life change
considerably without corresponding
changes in his Constitution
that is Modern Men
apes and monkeys live as they lived
millions of years ago
while human life changes radically and
very rapidly
it is extremely varied yet there is no
corresponding diversity within the human
species
take a child from a stone age culture
and raise him in New York
he will become a New Yorker
raise an American baby in New Guinea and
he will become a Papua native
the genetic differences one finds are
superficial and trivial but human beings
have the extraordinary characteristic of
being able to live in very different
ways
human beings have history cultural
Evolution and cultural differentiation
any objective scientists must be struck
by the qualitative differences between
human beings and other organisms as much
as by the difference between insects and
vertebrates
if not he is simply irrational
take an even more Elementary Criterion
proliferation
in that regard human beings are a
species with a remarkable biological
success
perhaps not if you compare them to
insects or chickens but here the
proliferation in fact results from Human
intervention
but compared to higher organisms monkeys
or chimpanzees for example
they are much more numerous
thus in the most Elementary respects
human beings are quite different
no scientist could fail to see that
even the most superficial observations
suffices to show that there are
qualitative differences between humans
and other complex organisms which must
be explained
if our hypothetical Martian Observer
searches a bit further you will find
that human beings are unique in many
respects
one of these being their ability to
acquire rich and varied linguistic
system
which can be used freely and in the most
subtle and complicated ways
merely by immersion in a linguistic
community in which the system is used
it seems to me that a rational Observer
would conclude that specific qualities
of intelligence proper to this species
must be assumed
if he is of an inquiring mind and
enterprising he will seek to determine
the genetically fixed mental structures
which underlie the unique achievements
of this species
I believe the rejection of innate ideas
also Springs from their association with
the Cartesian notion of Soul am
that may well be true
but consider this ancient problem of the
human soul in its historical context
for the cat for example the existence of
the soul is assumed in quite a rational
way as a scientific principle
in some respects his argument for the
existence of the soul is not very
different from Newton's argument for
Gravity as a force of nature
Descartes was wrong no doubt but his
procedure in itself was not at all
unreasonable
to see this it is sufficient to pursue
the analogy to Newton
though I don't want to exaggerate its
importance
Newton showed that Cartesian mechanics
could not account for the movement of
heavenly bodies
to explain this movement he postulated a
new Force
gravity attraction at a distance
that is a force which by the criteria of
his time was considered to be a cult
mystical because action at a distance
violated basic assumptions of mechanics
Newton showed that in this way one could
account for the facts though he too was
quite uncomfortable with the occult
Force he was postulating
this postulate became the common sense
of following Generations
with LaPlace and others an inconceivable
idea for pre-newtonian physics
subsequently became part of science
because of its remarkable explanatory
power
for his part Descartes believed wrongly
that push-pull mechanics could explain
all phenomena of the natural world
except such things as Consciousness and
human creativity
thus to explain what was beyond the
scope of his mechanics he postulated
another substance
little else was open to him given the
metaphysics of substance and accident to
which he was committed one can now
imagine all sorts of other things which
are not part of his mechanics
but let us suppose that Descartes or the
cartesians could have gone further and
invented a mathematics of the Mind
a successful explanatory Theory
then their belief would have become part
of the science of subsequent Generations
like the physics of Newton
to repeat
the existence of the soul the cat's
second substance is a scientific
proposition
it is false but it is not irrational
and he elaborated his theory of the soul
to an explanatory theory he might have
created a new science to supplement his
speculative physiology
he was completely right to propose new
principles and to seek out their
consequences
one might say that decath's belief that
the soul is a simple substance which
cannot be analyzed created an obstacle
to the development of an explanatory
theory of the Mind
a theory which in principle might be
assimilated to a suitably extended
physics
but that is an altogether different
question
a convincing rejection of his dualism
requires a demonstration that his
postulate is useless or unnecessary
because we can explain the properties of
the human mind in other ways
let us then look for such an explanation
it might turn out that we are led to new
principles when we inquire into the
nature of the Mind
it is conceivable though not
demonstrated that principles entirely
different from those of contemporary
physics enter into the explanation of
mental phenomena
and all these matters one must guard
against dogmatism
to make precise what you are opposing to
empiricism
I think it is important to remember that
for you the mental organ is that which
corresponds to the grammar and not to
the language
the structuralists think that one
memorizes extended sentences that is to
say the language long
and that this represents the grammar but
for you what is constructed in memory as
grammar is quite another thing
it is necessary to insist on this
difference because so often the set of
rules which makes the sentences of a
language possible is confused with the
language as a set of memorized sequences
on the contrary it was language long
which was deposited in memory
he could not distinguish the memory
which we can have of this or that
extended sentence from the memory of the
grammatical form
the situation is quite different here
the two kinds of memory are different
the construction of the grammar is due
to the language faculty but don't you
think that another confusion can arise
because of the ambiguity of the English
word language both lung and longash
therefore one could understand that it
is the language as long which is innate
which would be absurd of course if
French were innate I would speak it
is the mechanism of language acquisition
that is innate in a given linguistic
Community children with very different
experience arrive at comparable grammars
indeed almost identical ones
so far as We Know
that is what requires explanation even
within a very narrow community
take the elite in Paris the experiences
are varied each child has a different
experience each child is confronted by
different data but in the end the system
is essentially the same
as a consequence we have to suppose that
all children share the same internal
constraints which characterize narrowly
the grammar they are going to construct
this hypothesis also explains why when
the moment of maturation is passed
adolescence it is no longer possible to
learn a language
the wolf children never learn to speak
and we speak a foreign language which we
have learned late in life with an accent
without these biological constraints
foreign accent would be inexplicable
yes there seems to be a critical age for
learning a language
as is true quite generally for the
development of the human body
patterns of growth are determined
genetically for example sexual
maturation to take a case that occurs
long after birth
it would evidently be absurd to maintain
that only what one sees at Birth is
determined genetically
even death to a certain degree is
genetically determined
to say that the genetically determined
properties of an organism cannot
manifest themselves before the
appropriate conditions exist
and that in general the genetic program
is spelled out in a way that is partly
predetermined and partly influenced by
environmental factors
is a virtual truism
in the study of physical development it
is a common place and once again if the
methodological dualism of empiricist
Dogma is abandoned
there is no reason to be surprised by
the discovery of similar phenomena in
the study of higher mental functions